well
[Music]
hello how are you greetings to héctor mejía
with the brief informative for today Thursday
March 11 health experts
are advising those over
65 to get vaccinated against the
coronavirus there are appointments available now
leaders say that approximately  70%
of that group needs to get the vaccine
in order to open other
categories so that more people receive it.
Yesterday, Congress approved a
rescue package for the coronavirus. This includes
28 points, 6 billion for
independent restaurants, plus 22
billion in  housing assistance
for all states 125 billion
for the reopening of public schools
more than 1 billion for events that
closed due to the pandemic 470
million for libraries and museums there will
also be an expansion to the benefits
of obama care in addition to an increase
of 15  percent for food stamps
better known as food
systems monday the vice president as
the g  January this week they will visit Las
Vegas' more information will be revealed in
the coming days this is the second
family trip since he took
office and now we turn to
the weather forecast we will have another chance of
drizzle for the valley today
with temperatures  lows
around 50 degrees it will continue to rain
tomorrow but a sunny weekend is expected
have a nice day I am
héctor mejía and this was your brief
information on Spanish ginseng